[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
loïc est un citoyen suisse de 25 ans le
14 novembre 2017
il a décidé d'agir il a donc déposé une
pétition dont il est le seul et l'unique
signataires sur le bureau du grand
conseil genevois
notre parlement cantonal ces propos
mettait en avant le problème bien
présent de la pollution plastique en
suisse n'importe quel citoyen peut
effectivement par le biais d'une
pétition protesté et demandé à être
entendu ce sera le cas de loïc qui sera
auditionné dans la commission de
l'environnement dans laquelle je fais
mais tout tout tout premiers pas
politiques
après avoir écouté loïc nous écoutons
aussi les milieux concernés par cette
thématique les services de l'état qui
nous explique avoir déjà fourni beaucoup
d'efforts à l'issue de nos travaux toute
la commission décide d'envoyer cette
pétition au gouvernement
signe que nous approuvons son contenu
mais c'est un geste symbolique dont rien
de concret ne découle réellement
puisqu'en fait une pétition
même si elle contient des dizaines de
milliers de signatures n'a strictement
aucun n'est fait contraignant alors avec
une autre collègue
nous décidons d'aller plus loin nous
rédigeons cette fois ci un projet de loi
qui vise à ancrer dans la loi
l'interdiction des sacs plastiques sur
notre canton
nous assistons alors à une levée de
boucliers des juristes vous ne pouvez
pas faire ça ce n'est pas possible c'est
une compétence fédérale genève ne peut
pas décider de faire ça tout seul bon
en revanche nous pouvions interdire la
mise à disposition gratuite de ces mêmes
sacs plastiques et encourager les
alternatives il est vrai que notre
système pour sa construction différencie
ce qui est une compétence fédérale donc
de la suisse de ce que les cantons dans
leur autonomie respectives peut faire ce
projet de loi sera à lui aussi
travailler en commissions et quelques
mois plus tard
adopté à l'unanimité de notre parlement
loïc avait donc été entendu succès que
s'empressa de relativiser une collègue
un petit peu plus à droite que moi elle
me pose à deux questions après nos
travaux la première était la suivante
sérieusement tu pense vraiment qu'on a
sauvé la planète et les océans
j'ai répondu non certainement pas mais
nous avions fait un tout petit bout de
chemin
sa deuxième question était la suivante
est ce que tu penses vraiment qu'on
avait le choix de cette démarche à
nouveau j'ai répondu certainement pas
mais nous avions construit du concret
ensemble avec le hic
et cette histoire démontre l'accès
qu'aujourd'hui un simple citoyen peut
avoir sur le politicien le lien entre
politique et citoyen est infiniment
complexe parce que la politique est
avant tout un citoyen et que dans une
période de perte de confiance
le citoyen doit s'investir il existe
aujourd'hui un pont d'accès aux
politiciens élus qui n'est plus
intouchable il doit prendre ses
responsabilités en travaillant en
préparant ces dossiers en consultant les
milieux concernés pour rendre compte de
ces paroles et de ces actions les
attentes ont changé transparence
honnêteté représentativité ce sont des
exigences de la population qui lui donne
le pouvoir
elle veut des réponses rapides des
changements concrets et efficaces ce qui
n'est pas toujours très compatible avec
la lenteur de nos institutions
politiques et démocratiques en suisse le
politicien aujourd'hui doit assumer les
conséquences de ses actions
d'ailleurs quel moment après le projet
de loi qui nous est venue de loïc je me
retrouve au marché près du maraîcher à
qui j'achète mes légumes et il me tend
mes achats dans un sac plastique
il faut savoir que la loi sera appliquée
uniquement début 2022 parce que vous
comprenez il fallait laisser le temps à
tous ceux qui avaient acheté des stocks
importants
de les écouler plutôt que de les jeter
donc il est là il me tend mes légumes
il me dit vous savez madame bientôt je
ne pourrez plus vous en donner ça va
être interdite alors un tout petit peu
gêné je lui répond effectivement je suis
au courant je fais partie des gens qui
m'initier cette démarche
et là il me regarde un peu étonné alors
oui bon je fais de la politique ce qui
ne m'empêche pas de faire mes courses
comme l'entièreté des citoyens de ce
pays et il me dit vous savez vous avez
raison c'est complètement ridicule de
donner un sac plastique avec une
courgette dedans tout en sachant que dix
minutes plus tard il sera jeté à la
poubelle
donc quand je dis que nous sommes
confrontés aux conséquences de nos actes
c'est du vécu
probablement qu'il y a quelques années
loïc n'aurait pas été entendue
considéré comme trop jeune ces propos
comme insignifiant pas suffisamment
important pour être pris en compte
mais aujourd'hui l'accès aux
informations
la puissance des médias des réseaux
sociaux ont changé fondamentalement la
donne
et puis en parallèle certains scandales
ont éclaté à genève et ailleurs dans le
monde est aujourd'hui la population
n'accepte plus en silence certaines
frasques et certains comportements
il ne faut pas oublier que sur son siège
confortable d'élus le politicien dois te
rendre des comptes à toi citoyen
citoyenne qu'il est là où il est grâce à
toi et que demain sous la pression
publique
il peut tomber de très haut car au final
rien n'est plus éphémère que ce pouvoir
qui lui est prêté alors aujourd'hui à
toi qui comme le hic a quelque chose à
dire à toi qui défilent dans la rue pour
le climat et l'environnement à toi qui
manifestent parce que l'égalité tu la
veux maintenant et pas dans vingt ans à
toi patronne d'entreprise qui croule
sous les papiers à toi père de famille
qui n'arrivent plus à payer des primes
d'assurance maladie
n'oubliez pas une chose c'est que le
pouvoir est aussi entre tes mains et que
le politicien
élu toi te rendre des comptes continuent
de lui ouvrir les yeux et réclame ce kit
est dû mais n'oublie pas non plus que
derrière le politicien se cache le
citoyen l'humain qui sera parfois lassé
d'être sollicité en continu je n'aurais
pas toujours envie de te répondre après
avoir enchaîné les séances la politique
le travail parfois un peu de famille je
me serais parfois fait insulter par
email ou pris à partie dans la rue pour
ce que j'ai défendu comme opinion je
n'aurais pas particulièrement en
permanence envie de t'expliquer pourquoi
je pense différemment surtout quand
cette en plein repas de famille et que
ce mon père mon mari mon frère qui
critique qui m'explique ce que je
devrais faire j'aimerais bien que quand
je vais en soit rayé qu'on apprend que
je fais de la politique
on arrête de me demander si moi aussi
j'ai droit à un ordinateur un voyage et
tous ces fabuleux avantage parce que si
je suis là c'est avant tout par amour du
bien commun et parce que je veux être
actrice du monde de demain kas est
régulièrement j'ai envie de laisser
tomber parce que je me sens coincé dans
un non choix entre ce que je pense ce
que j'aimerais ce qu'il faudrait est ce
que tout le monde me raconte
et pourtant continuent à m'interpeller à
m'écrire
car ce sont ces sollicitations qui me
pousse en permanence à me remettre en
question pour tenter de m'améliorer et
d'être meilleur dans ce que je fais au
final nous avons signé pour répondre à
tes préoccupations
c'est le seul choix que nous ayons
réellement fait le reste n'est qu'à
prendre à naviguer dans un océan de
contraintes
vous l'aurez compris aujourd'hui la
relation entre le politique et le
citoyen est désormais intense mais elle
permet de dessiner
si comme moi vous êtes optimiste un
nouveau mode de gouvernement plus à l
écoute plus proche dé loïc qui osent
plus honnête au contact des citoyens
et représentatif de notre diversité
c'est du moins ce que je crois ce que
j'espère est ce que j'ai envie de vous
transmettre aujourd'hui soyez comme le
hic
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]